[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from 14 nations converge in st.
Louis as US chess champs calm presents
the third annual spring chess Classic
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for coverage of hump day it's
round five of the 2019 spring chess
classic you like that a month I like
that all right like that damn good my
name is Ben Simon and I'm joined as
always by Grandmaster chess brah I'm on
Hambleton and we have several games
already completed because remember the
rounds begin earlier then we go on the
air but let's take a look at this log
jam we have in Group A right now we have
a six way tie or at least we did coming
into the round Michnik Zhang tari Liam
Lee Robson and Hanson most of the field
tied at the top are you surprised by
this amount
yeah it just shows what a tough field
this is overall like even being the top
seed playing the lowest seed in the
tournament you can't expect that as a
free point these players are also strong
and we can see early on a six way tie
for first place definitely indicates
that you know there's there's really no
clear favorites here and let's glance at
Group B it's a different story
altogether because leading by a full
point coming in today by Jin Chi from
China who is also the number one seed
and we'll see if anybody can stop the
momentum that the Chinese player has in
this field
yeah he's off to a really good start and
probably the most dominant performance
in either field so far from by Jin sheep
but obviously it's a long tournament and
he needs to keep up the pace if he wants
to continue this way before we get to
the games we'd like to introduce you to
the format if you're just joining us for
the first time it's a round-robin event
two of them to be specific in a group
and a B group 90 minutes for the first
40 moves on each o'clock and then 30
minutes are added on for the remainder
of the game the good thing about this
show is you get to see the time
scrambles and the time trouble before
they get that extra 30 moves all right
30
and there is a 30 second increment from
move number one there is a draw rule in
place the players cannot agree to a draw
before blacks thirtieth move to
encourage fighting chess as we glance at
our schedule you will see that it's the
same time every day except for the final
round
1:00 p.m. start time for the games at
u.s. chess champs calm and then at 3:30
p.m. we will be on the air with you to
tell you about the conclusions of the
rounds and we encourage you to join us
all along the way on social media at us
chess champs calm the YouTube chat is
open and if you haven't yet remember to
subscribe and we will the glanced at
your comments and if they are
thought-provoking enough or funny enough
I might just read them on the air mostly
funny
maybe yeah it's really just we just want
the funny yeah it's got to be funny or
else well frankly it's boring yeah ok so
here are the pairings going on right now
in our masters group a now three of
these games I understand have already
finished
we have Vasilyev on Chuck vs. Rustom
chasm Jean of Benjamin Bach vs. alien is
Nick Arion tari vs. Ray Robson Eric
Hanson vs. Jeffrey Zhang and well one of
the games that's still going on
grandmasters Liam Lee and var Akopian
are playing today this is our one to
watch we have the leader
Liam Lee vs. Akopian one of st. Louis's
favorite sons now remember one draw
classic in classic play these players
have had against each other this is
their record that's it
however in it may have been rapid it may
have been blitz Liam Lee did get a
victory over a co peon but it was 11
years ago at the mine sports chess event
which was rapid in blitz it was a
combination of a whole bunch of
different games and rest happened to be
one of them so let's glance at this game
and see where we are well as he
mentioned then we got a lot of games
finished so far in the a group but this
is one that's still ongoing here
actually
just taking this one from the opening
although it started with c4 we can
actually see that the game quickly
transposed into a Queen's Gambit
exchange variation where white takes on
d5 and the ideas that he wants to get
rid of any of these D takes c4 ideas
none of this Queens gambit accepted
stuff he's going to play Bishop g5 next
and usually one of the main plans of
this opening is that you want to play
III Bishop d3 and actually not Knight to
f3 but Knight G to e2 so putting this
night on e 2 and then leaving this F
pawn free to maybe play F 3 and E 4
later in the center so that's one of the
biggest ideas from the opening but
actually what we see is a line that I
play is white quite often which is when
black plays Bishop a5 here you know
usually there's no way that that black
should be able to get away with getting
c6 in and Bishop f5 so we could say in
this position if Bishop f5 the normal
way to deal with this is to go and hit
that pawn on b7 straight away and say
that the bishop being absent from c8 is
immediately felt in order to facilitate
the bishops development you want to play
c6 now after e3 again if black tries to
get that Bishop there there has to be a
way to punish this because in the Queens
gambit if black is ever allowed to
achieve c6 and Bishop f5 97 Bishop d6
he's doing very very well
so Queen f3 this is the the whole point
of this opening after Bishop g6 you
double and isolate those pawns and
that's the position that bar is dealing
with although this position is very
theoretical it's been discussed before
there's a very nice game between Magnus
Carlsen and Vladimir Kramnik
or Carlsen had the white pieces in this
line and pretty much showed exactly what
we see laQuan we am doing here I think
Carlsen brought to light this idea of
Knight c2e2
and the idea of bringing the knight to
g3 putting the knight on f5 playing g4
Bishop d3 and because of that var
actually decide to play f5 and although
it looks silly double isolated pawns on
the H file it's actually this bishop
which is looking
more like a pond the harder you look at
it so why is trying to play in the dark
squares here and both sides with doubled
isolated pawns should slightly favor
white although this line definitely has
a very equal reputation so going forward
here
the players are I mean look long is
playing on the dark squares here he's
got the better bishop but at the same
time black is really really solid here
as you can see he's watching that F pawn
it's the only weakness in the position
and after he sort of locks everything up
here he's gonna stick the knight on e4
or g4 and there he goes 94 and the movie
four played so that black doesn't have
time to maybe just solidify here he
could play King g6
or King f6 double the rooks get that
bishop in there he has all sorts of ways
to to try to play this but a lot of
pressure on the e-file so what does the
quang do
efore on move 25 and now things really
open up he takes the pawn on h5 and you
have to wonder in the position that's on
the board right now after rookie 5k f6
we are in a complete rook endgame it's
actually white who has the funny-looking
pawns three sets of isolated pawns one
of them doubled isolated on the h-file
but that King is going to come very
nicely into e3 however the more that you
look at a position like this it is a
rook endgame the pawns are I believe
equal yes the pawns are equal and black
is always going to have counter play
either on the H file and then of King g3
maybe back to the D file and hit this
fun so the King can't be in both places
at once although it would like to be and
well without going too deep in this
position
it looks offhand like white is maybe
maybe prefer just with this strong rook
here you're already sort of enticing
black to try to trade and fix your pawns
for you and get rid of the hard work
each v can be played to protect this
pawn there maybe bring the King III and
meanwhile we have this extra rope for
white that can serve roam around whether
it's going to g1 whether it's going to
go in the rook lift and start to bother
these Queen side pawns probably a fairly
fairly even here I would say Ben but
maybe maybe I slightly prefer white but
I think it
I think it's relatively equal I notice
that bar got that Bishop off the board
as soon as possible
the the big pond bishop yes so would you
imagine that
Liam Lee can go on to win this or are
you predicting draw number four for this
field today well I think that if laQuan
won this position I would classify that
as maybe one of the most impressive
results from the tournament so far draw
it is yeah but he can he can push he can
play on but I don't think var is is too
concerned here and laQuan Yin and far
seem to be playing a pretty even game so
far all right well let's jump on over to
our b group and in this field there are
no games that have ended yet gregory cut
donna versus he had in stein crimson
sergey Ehrenburg versus Andre baarish
poets Alexander Mesa versus Denis CAD
rich Alexey Sorokin versus Christian
korilla and our key matchup of the day
actually international master Nicolas
theodoro versus the front-runner of the
field grandmaster by ginchy
now if the adora wins he joins by at the
top of the field but let's see if he is
what's the verdict is theodoro matching
vayan she on the board well let's see
it's really important game obviously for
for him because as you mentioned not
only is it just about climbing up into
the standings trying to get to that
first place spot but I mean every every
point is important when you're you're
trying to score that norm so we have a
position here where it's actually black
to move and if we do a simple pawn count
that's one extra pawn right there on c64
by Jin Chi I want to quickly take a look
at maybe how that pawn was lost here as
we just jumped from the start
theodoro playing white and by Jin she
with the black pieces so these positions
are looking fairly fairly standard so
far
Queen d1 played by Nicholas and he goes
on this sort of a expedition win this
pawn back
so d takes c4 was played and then he
goes 90 day four with tempo 95 with
tempo hitting these two queen c8 Queen
c2 wants to take that pawn and finally
he does reclaim it
but the LightSquared Bishop sket traded
which you know it leaves this guy pretty
happy from g7 and whites King a little
bit weaker although nothing to worry
about but it seems like here he he must
have just got outplayed in the middle
game because losing that pawn on d4
Knight c5 Queen c8 I mean it's it's
almost like black just sort of ganged up
on the pawn and white white just didn't
defend b5 and the pawn was lost so I
think it's it really comes down to you
know III which defends the pawn is just
not a very nice move to play it blocks
your bishop in from c1 it also makes
these light squares around the King so
much weaker for example if I play them
III here there might be strangely enough
the crazy move Knight h4 check and if I
take that we see the light squares being
exposed here as Queen g4 and Queen takes
d1 comes in the position which would
just be winning for black so it's almost
as if he he thought that at any time he
could defend this pawn with e3 you know
I've got it covered it's no worries but
then it came time to okay one two three
got a defendant and he probably
calculated wait a minute
you know Knight age four is actually
maybe it's just a big concern here in
the position so so it's best to lose the
pawn right there this well I think he
just overlooked this e3 thing and he
doesn't want to lose the pawn so he
played Knight b3 which defends it but
then after the movie five happens the
problem is Queen here you have to deal
with a5 ideas you also have to deal with
Knight takes followed by c5 forking the
Queen and knight on d4 and if Queen d3
you're also walking straight into that
pin so you could just take that pawn for
free
so yeah it seems to me like it's
actually a weird sort of tactic but he
was probably relying on the movie 3 to
save his pawn in a lot of lines and then
it's like whoopsies such a weird tactic
but night h4 in the position maybe was
was working it's it's a kind of a
strange situation but it means that
after b5 Queen c2 he kind of just loses
a pawn here and here he can actually
take that pawn back but you're probably
gonna be faced with a lot of counter
play for example very quickly I could
see an idea like rook c8 and maybe that
Queen down at d1 and just these pieces
are not playing the game so he went for
the movie for he wants to get that
Bishop out and I still got a reasonable
position but upon he's a part man and he
is going to be suffering here with half
the time on the clock and maybe an
oversight in the middle game with that
III move this is what it looks like from
my perspective here yeah this really
doesn't look good for Nikolas
bhaijan she you know he he's fresh off
his victory at the North American Open
and I think I might be speaking a little
early but he's definitely he's
definitely looking in great position
great positions great fun as well so far
is that as I mentioned yesterday on the
broadcast Ben he just hasn't been
visibly in trouble in any game he hasn't
been down on the clock and he hasn't
been in in a worse position we really
had to see him maybe pull out those
defensive skills we don't really know
what it's like for a frame and play from
the back foot in this event so far so
it's really gonna take some testing to
to see if you know anyone can expose
some some areas of weakness all right
well that's our look at our key matchups
so let's see what the players are
fighting for let's first take a look at
our prize fund for group a where the
champion walks away with $6,000 one
thing to remember in these fields is
everybody gets something so there's
something to play for there's something
to win you're not gonna lose money
coming to st. Louis so low-risk
high-reward but I think the players want
that $6,000 and in our be group
the grand prize is four thousand dollars
total combined prize fund very generous
36 grand as always the classics are
really delivering and we've got three
more scheduled later this year we hope
you join us all along the way okay so
I'm wondering as I'm looking at the
computer evals right now are we gonna
have five draws today in Group A well
the other games still aren't going but
we haven't looked at is Vasily even
shook against roost M chasm Jan oh I see
that game here as it's underway and I
think it really comes down to to how
well Vasily can play with the rook
because normally then I mean I'm looking
at these two pieces and unless there is
unless one of those pieces is being lost
or something like that
it should be you'd rather have the two
minors overhead it should be preferred
to be black here but that being said
there are a few things to consider
number one I have this check which it
activates my rook one of your pieces has
to block on a square you don't really
want to go to and then I can sort of
bring the rook over here right and I can
sort of pick which pawn I want to target
so from my perspective as white I always
have that as a fail-safe to get that
rook in there the other thing that I
think almost everyone would consider
then is is really important I move like
rook e1
like this move just pins all three
pieces and let's say I play a normal
move like Queen d7 the idea is just
simply if I move the Queen over you're
losing a piece they're there they're
just skewered all the way down the
e-file so I believe that the way this is
being dealt with is it looks like Queen
f8 has been played and he did go Queen
f8 right because I think black has a way
to deal with this which might involve
Queen to g6 with the idea that if you
sort of stack up on the e-file that I'll
play Bishop here and threatening me so
you don't have time to grab my knight
which which sort of gets out of that
which explains why he didn't go for that
instead he did go
this cheque takes takes TASM janap has
to decide what piece is gonna put there
and then this rope gets to sort of pick
and choose rook da trophy it rook a
you're probably gonna win at the very
least one pawn and that's why you know
maybe this is a little more equal than
it initially seemed because there is
counter play for that white rook in this
position and maybe black has to be
careful if you lose both of these pawns
suddenly that a pawn very very scary can
we go a little bit deeper I want to see
how much damage that white can act that
rook can hear yeah well it depends which
piece so Kasim Jana off here with 33
minutes
he has to decide first of all if he
decides to go with the night then it's a
little easier to calculate at least for
white because you can just try to stay
on the dark squares it's seems to be in
my interest to go and take these pawns
if I can so let's say if I went here
then the bishop goes to d5 sits on c6
pawn goes to a6 and actually everything
is is pretty much covered so it seems to
me like maybe the knight is the better
piece to move back for for black here
and if I go Brooke a8 I can just play a
six or b8 I always have bishop here and
so it looks like at the end of the day
it's gonna be the deep on that falls if
black goes Knight to g8 okay work d8 and
then here I have to lose this pawn maybe
I even do the same move let's leave
Bishop here and Bishop back to c6 and
now I'm gonna you know make an escape
square get my night out and it's gonna
be a broken one pawn for the two pieces
and we could definitely see this one
being more more on the equal side rather
than preferring the two pieces as y can
probably find a way to trade a lot of
those pawns on the Queen side and it
feels to me like 98 is probably the
right the right choice if you go with
the bishop then it only seems like I
have you know more freedom for example
rook here now I'm hitting this pawn if
you want to save it you go there now I
go rook b7 and I'm hitting these two
I'm just not sure about the
repercussions like knight c6 broke here
you already get in trouble because
bishop here you're gonna be losing a
piece and you have to bring your Bishop
back maybe something crazy like Knight
c8 can hold with Bishop e6 maybe
something like this but it's really hard
to it's really hard to tell here between
these three rook moves why is probably
going to get upon no matter what and I
think first M has a lot of good options
here whether it's the knight or the
bishop but in fact he has indeed chosen
a knight I think that is very safe
option okay so if we have the knight is
right now what if white preps with c4 to
keep the bishop off of d5 right
unfortunately I have other ways to get
there so I can just start with Bishop
here and even hit upon which means that
okay you have to play five or b3
whatever it is and then I can plant this
Bishop back where I want it play a six
and again I'm only going to be losing
this pawn and black will slowly get its
pieces out so I think that long term
that the you're only losing one pond the
night and bishops still work better than
the rook together so I feel like you've
on check is still on the slightly worse
end of this note no question but do I
think it's winning for black maybe not
but with that time pressure mounting you
can see here twelve moves to make in six
minutes for vasili even check plus the
fact that it's it's so hard to deal with
two minor pieces coordinating I think
Kasim jennife might might just be doing
it very well here well there's more than
meets the eye to this one that's for
sure okay so already we've looked at all
the active games and group a yeah that
that's because Michnik and Benjamin Bach
had a draw ray Robson and re and tari
had a draw and Eric Hanson and Geoffrey
Jean also had a draw and and all of
these I can't say that they were
necessarily all quick draws I think
Hansen's was maybe arguably the quickest
or the least the least action but right
at 30 moves
yeah but Michnik and and Bach did have a
fighting a bit of a fighting game I saw
analyzing it upstairs in the club and
this was the final position in that one
so the two bishops therefore white I
think the the feeling of the players
during that game was that Nick was
fighting for a draw pretty much the
whole time so yeah I think he was happy
to to escape with a draw here but as you
mentioned three draws there it's looking
pretty draw or or equal in look long
Liam and VARs game so actually it feels
like this end game between the Yvonne
Chuck and Kasim Janna I was gonna be
crucial and otherwise all the action
appears to be in the B group today yeah
and I think that's where we should go
right now I'd like to look at Sergei
Ehrenburg versus Andre bars pullets the
former winter classic B champion and
that pond that upon that looks a little
scary but there's a lot of pieces
protecting it there potentials for pins
here looks kind of dangerous here for
black well this looks like an Arenberg
position were using by that we have seen
so far that Sergei
Arenberg really doesn't hold back he
doesn't hold back at all and personally
as just a chess fan I find that very
exciting we remember his game against
Christian korilla where both sides were
attacking in very exciting fashion so he
really is not afraid to go for it here
and with that pawn on e6 and his Knight
hanging on g5 you have to feel like he
is you know with less than five minutes
left he's trying to concoct some sort of
attack get the tactics flowing here I'm
a little curious how we got there from
such a regular very low PES opening and
we see okay this 95 90 X b3 line but
still these positions don't tend to open
up as much as that usually but Ehrenburg
has spent a lot of time and in exchange
he has traded the dark square bishop and
then he's thrown this on the e6 now it
requires a lot of calculation here but
after ecigs I mean one of the most
obvious moves has got to be just Knight
takes what if we take that pawn off the
board get our piece off the last rank I
mean this is one of the most logical
moves I can think of we have to sort of
think what is Arenberg planning here
so if
well if I take obviously we want to take
with the bishop we don't want to ever
take with the pawn they're after Bishop
takes is he up - so Queen here looks
like yeah that's what I was thinkin
looks like what he's what he intends and
then if we see this bishop move there is
rook takes and pick up that rock in the
corner so there's a tactic if you can't
play Bishop but what I mean play queen
da right and which position it takes the
road oh you can play Queen d8 but the
problem is you lost a piece there
don't forget cuz I did grab on D Senate
so if you do the body count at the end
even though you can save your at your
other rook here
I've already snagged a bishop so King d8
or kingi 7 let's say probably one of the
only moves King on fader Keeney 7 and
he's trying to say it I mean like this
looks like a great position the king is
is out in the open
maybe King f8 is actually the necessary
move but for the price of a pawn I mean
this guy is just following with check I
got this King out in the open this this
can't be can't be right so that looks
like a very good line for Arenberg so
there you go we just discounted probably
one of the most obvious moves just for
the viewers I think pawn takes because
it does stop the check I think that
there's a decent chance here then that
this runs into maybe a a funky move
Knight f6 check takes Queen g6 if King
e7 I have this check and the rook stops
the King from going forwards and if you
have to go back you lose this rook in
the corner so that would be winning for
white and if King f8 after Queen g6 I'm
hitting your rook in the corner the King
has to go this way again and then here I
just don't see any refutation to the
simple idea of I mean Rover why don't I
just like rook d3 and bring the rover
over I mean this looks this looks just
checkmate on the board so that's the
refutation to Knight takes c6 I believe
the other move that comes to mind is
Bishop takes you six what about this one
once again
simple Knight takes needs to be needs to
be calculated if Queen takes I think it
you know bottom line is I can take this
pawn on c7 and at least be okay here if
Knight takes then once again Queen c6
check and you know why are we playing
this way with black where our King is
running around I mean this is this is
kind of crazy
if pawn takes then I'm looking at this
move again and I'm wondering does it
work and I'm thinking that it doesn't
because one move would be actually yeah
just King here Queen g7 and now I have
this Knight so that's a big difference
now I have this Knight there so I think
that that maybe is what bearish poets is
is calculating right now but from a
quick process of elimination there I
think Knight takes doesn't work at all
and I think Bishop takes you may have to
recapture with the pawn unless you want
to take your King for a jog you're gonna
be faced with Queen c6 checks so Knight
takes maybe pawn takes and try to get
try to get castle next turn right but
enterprising sacrifice from sergey aaron
berger move Bishop takes c6 has been
played on the board I wonder if he's
just gonna grab this right away I think
it looks like a good move maybe the best
move and it's hard for me to think of
another one maybe rook takes d8 is on
his mind but I just don't think it works
I noticed that White has doubled his
pawns on the B file and while it's a
little bit ways away from what we've
been focusing on is that is that a
double pawn situation that is especially
bad or can you kind of discount it well
I think it really depends been on on
whether these Queens are on the board or
not if they're off the board I think
this is especially bad it's a sitting
duck for this Bishop you know blacks
even got his extra pollen on that side
of the board so it starts to even become
maybe a to 100 over there if I went upon
and make it pass pawn for the middle
game though I think it actually affords
white an open a file open C file and
he's putting those to use right now so I
think it really just depends Queens on
the board or not right now I don't think
these pawns are an issue but Sergei
Arenberg is kind of in an all in
position here he's just played a six you
get the feeling that with with the clock
ticking down
and his current position that he is kind
of all in and so I don't think he's too
concerned about those double pawns
because you know he could sort of keep
the Queens on the board and maintain the
pressure but it does look like bars
poets is gonna be under the gun if I
take here pawn takes looking to castle
maybe you move like Queen c5 just saying
nope you're not castling right now and I
do not like the look of this position
you can hardly move anything and they're
all on the last rank these double pawns
are not going to be his primary concern
in fact he has just played rook d8 on
the board I can't say that I looked too
deep at this move so it's quite possible
that this is this is a great move by
white but offhand it seemed like like it
wasn't working so let's see what he is
calculating so after if Queen takes one
right so Queen takes I'm wondering
whether we throw in this move or whether
we throw in this move first I get the
feeling that this is going to be
stronger and then we could play rook d1
now and then next get Queen c6 check
maybe something like that so like Queen
here Queen c6 king over but there are
few things you have to be a oh sorry
King up to f7 so we don't just drop that
rook with check and then rook d7 and
unfortunately rook d8 kind of a tricky
move doesn't work because that's
unfortunately a check so there's no time
for checkmate there so actually it seems
like that's his idea if Cain takes on d8
then we have to calculate once again but
rook d1 again looks like a very good
move here
let's save rook t1 Shack if King be
seven it doesn't matter because I can
have a check to force you to go to d8
and then maybe maybe Queen c6 check
again if Bishop there we have rook takes
and Queen takes 88 is an idea and
King f8 just Knight takes c6 and you
can't take with the Queen because the
rook is hanging again in the corner so
pawn takes and I have a feeling after
rook d7 it is going to be a checkmate on
the board they're coming soon or at
least a very very strong attack
so Brooke d8 appears to be a good move
at first glance but there's certainly
some more variations here and he's
played it with two minutes 28 on the
clock and baarish bullets now has to
sort of uncover what what he's thinking
yeah and only yeah I'm not sure if you
mention it we're only like 22 moves into
this game it's a good point yeah though
they have a long way to go until time
control barely even halfway there right
and Arenberg i mean the story of his
tournament has been attacking chess in
time trouble that those two things don't
often go hand in hand but there they've
been going hand in hand for him in this
game but honestly he seems to seems to
be fairly in control of this attack
right here if I had to say blacks
position is looking a shaky or and shaky
or the more you calculate deep into
these variations been very well okay
let's go on to our next game in Group B
Alexei Sorokin defeat I master the lone
feed a master against Grandmaster count
Christian Corolla right so in this game
let's see a counting material we have
both of the kings you like this
structure for the Kings right here with
the pawn slanted toward the edge of the
board I think this is fairly standard
we had a position just yesterday between
facility von Schuch and Ilya nation and
we actually had the pawns slanted the
other way with the pawn on f5 like this
so that was for white in that position
and the first thing I said was when the
rook gets down to the second rank you
get this feeling like you're just you're
cut off
right you can't join so the way that the
pawns are in this position is actually a
lot more standard and makes way more
sense because you you have shelter for
your king but the same time you're still
gaining space and you're preventing that
annoying you know H pawn running up the
board against your castle King so
I think this is fairly standard here
what's more important is over the last
couple moves if we look here it actually
I think Sorokin has he dropped a pawn
yeah 97 so is this a five move by by
Sorokin which looks good because I mean
hey here you've got pawns on light
squares and light square bishop but I
think that he may have just overlooked
or maybe nothing he can do about night
here night there and hey that's a pawn
so Bishop d3 92 96 and he just takes a
pawn so I mean there's no way that that
is by design then that is a blunder
right there he just he just lost that
pawn on a 5-4 no compensation at all was
I mean could he have lost it and was
there anything he could have done or did
he lose it right as soon as but he had
some resort to this move no question he
had to play this but the problem is like
for example his move Bishop d3 after 97
if I play rook a 1 now Knight here how
do I defend this is only one Square and
then before so really his bad move was
Bishop d3 you don't have time for that
you have to play maybe even move like
rook a 1 now and after Knight here
you got to move this night so that after
Knight there you can clear your queen to
come back and then maintain defense of
a5 but you can see you already have to
make quite a lot of concessions and he
just never saw it coming so he played
Bishop d3 sort of nonchalant 97
whoopsies now there's no time for rookie
1 no time for any defense and see here
that is uh that's just a pawn for
Christian korilla now am i a big fan of
the movie 5 afterwards not particularly
it feels correct in the sense that you
absolutely want to you know open up this
Bishop will be dangerous for the White
King if takes takes but I start to get a
little concerned about maybe the dark
squares in this position that night
establishing itself on d4 rook
establishing itself on c7 Queen c2 as
has been played in the game what is the
idea with this well if that Knight moves
let's just let's say we go even
years to illustrate as Queen takes g6
and checkmate in one in the position as
that rook is hitting that pawn so that's
just something to keep your eye on when
the screen goes to see to it is menacing
the idea of Queen takes g6 in the future
but of course Kirill is definitely aware
of that but you know it's not like you
play these moves so that a strong player
misses them you play them because it
restricts that strong player to you know
e that's a Ty's night down to defense of
that pawn now so this is getting to be a
tense position for Carrillo who
seemingly just one upon but then now
it's gotten totally messy I feel like in
this position I I'd want to advance my
King kind of like how black has is king
on g7 I know I don't want to put the
King on g2 of course because d4 looks
potentially devastating devastating but
what about HD King h2 does it do me any
good or is it just an aesthetic
insecurity you raise a good point but
it's absolutely here an aesthetic
insecurity because King h2 simply runs
into all these checks that are gonna
force you to go somewhere else so really
what you should be doing is probably
playing Knight d4 blocking that pawn and
then putting it on g2 is g2 is where it
wants to go it's just very very
dangerous with that bishop there so I
would play first night there it also
stops a knight check from Black Knight
g4 is like the perfect move I think
that's exactly what you want to do you
want that King on G tube you have to
facilitate it first korilla has played
the move Queen to d2 in order to have
Knight f3 check come in let's say you
take check where does this King have to
go it has to go here on that diagonal
very scary and then you take that Queen
so for example here and what am I gonna
do before I take this and probably I
think that's it it's an idea to throw
this in but okay I'll just take this
because there's rook takes b7 and now I
have d4 Jack taking here and black would
be completely winning here so this Queen
d2 move cannot be taken definitely not
instead of taking on e3 at the end of
that variation would it behoove you just
to keep pushing
the pond on 2d three let's say King back
in this position D three right well D
three the only reason I get concerned
about this while it might actually be a
very very good move I get concerned
about ninety four and how maybe this
pawn is a little bit too far behind
enemy lines and I can't support it with
my ropes cuz that Knights in the way cut
off yeah
but the nice thing about pawn takes here
is you just absolutely shatter this pawn
structure and black just holds a sizable
advantage here Queen d2 has been played
and if Queen takes Knight f3 as we just
discussed so he's not gonna take that
Queen but then you know black gets that
Queen trade no more threat there you
have to remember there's one pawn extra
for black he's looking to try to convert
that here so what's the current position
is this it we are on it we are on at
Queen to d2 was the last move played not
from a 5 from v4 to d2 and Sorokin is
now thinking as Kirill is down to about
six minutes and thirteen moves to be
played well to reach time control but
gorilla has if you remember yesterday
basically played half his game on one
minute and he ended up winning
so clearly very very capable very
comfortable in that situation I may not
know a lot about Alexi Sorokin first
time viewers I mean we're seeing Sorokin
for the first time here and a longtime
viewers of our youtube channel might
know about the US Junior Championship
well Alexi Sorokin was the 2017 Russian
Junior Champion so the equivalent in
probably it's probably a pretty strong
tournament I don't have the names in
that but that was probably a really a
killer event a lot of untitled players
yeah yeah they like I skip titles over
there evidently yeah we don't know what
that's about it I am who cares about
that he's going to G in fact they
probably don't even know what it is over
there yeah they have two titles in the
system Ivan GU yeah of course of course
does it make sense to jump over to
Alexander Meester versus Dennis Ken rich
yeah we can look at that game
the position that I see on the board
there looks rather uninteresting but we
don't have to spend too much time on it
well in order to get here though the
middlegame simplified quite a lot
because I was looking at this position
sorry around this moment and it looked
like to me things were maybe going to
blow up because we have those two
bishops for CAD rich and we have the
extra pawn so we can see here ninety
four takes takes takes you went upon but
you know your King is fairly exposed the
bishops are gonna be strong and where
are the bishops strongest well in an
open position and that's what he does
here but unfortunately he has to give up
a bishop in order to get his pawn back
and I I mean maybe I could try to make
arguments for one side or the other here
then but at the end of the day I think
that I think that it's probably just
even the only question is whether black
can organize some initiative with like
he's just played rook d3 maybe Brooke t2
and hitting that bishop but both Kings
have an escape square both bishops are
placed right near the king that you know
maybe they're sort of vulnerable to
these batteries on the second-ranked on
the on the last rank but i think at the
end of the day this is this is actually
a fairly equal position and despite the
fireworks that i was expecting in the
middle game it seems like things have
sort of sort of petered out here yeah so
it's safe to call this one a likely draw
yes yes I think this one's a likely draw
just jumping back to the game we were
just on between Sorokin and korilla all
right either I missed something or I'm
incredibly surprised by what I see on
the board here which is yeah he has
taken that Queen and he's gone into the
line that we were talking about and
after Knight takes d - I mean your works
under attack you got to move it and then
comes Knight takes b1 and I don't think
there's any like tricky moves here
d4 what am I missing
ah here's what I'm missing I knew there
must be something as I mean this is just
a disaster line I think what he's
intending is
94 but 94 is a very tricky move so he
actually wants to play Knight takes B
194 so he's blocking this whole idea and
he's saying I'll take your knight later
it's actually trapped on b1 that's his
whole idea because it I was talking
about if he gets that night to d4
amazing position I mean he's really
recovering here he's still down upon
it's sitting there in a6 but I mentioned
earlier that Bishop on b7 is quite a bad
piece so even down upon white could even
make claims to to be better in this
position
what does 94 threaten his well then
Knight to e6 check winning material so
you have to be very careful as korilla
here the other thing to keep in mind is
that if in this position black goes d4
if you play d4 here giving that check
this was the reason I didn't want to
play the the variation in this order
which was because rook takes b7 was an
idea maybe he's gonna go for it rook
takes b7 takes takes takes takes and we
have one pawn plus the rook for the two
pieces plus the shattered pawn structure
so maybe maybe he's gonna go for that
because honestly if I'm korilla I'm
looking at this position here and I'm
thinking uh-oh if I take that Bishop 94
I don't like this position at all maybe
it's playable rook c8 because you still
have to take this Knight let's say rook
takes rook takes rook takes b1 maybe
he'll go for this and just bring the
King in but it doesn't look as good as
it once did
still the advantage for for korilla i
have a feeling he might go for this
position
just bring the King to the d6 the end of
the day you are up that one pawn try to
convert it but looks like a nice
combination by Sorokin at least to sort
of survive that position in better shape
than I thought he was yeah I mean for me
it looks like the rook on C is a big
difference maker here just I don't see
any of any way to ever regain control of
that file that pipe
no no way to do that the best we have is
just bringing a king over maybe try to
keep putting pawns on dark squares but
no other than that nothing special
nothing special all right
have we glanced at all of the games as
of now Kai Donovan Stein Grimm's and I I
don't think we know we'd have seen that
let's this is our last group B game that
we have yet to look at Gregory cut down
off with the white pieces here in Stein
Grimson with the black pieces and in
this position what do we have going on
because it seems to me like Stein
Grimson is really on the back foot here
however maybe maybe it's not that bad I
mean there's this annoying pin and
whites up a pawn but I can't say that
it's that bad yet because they're still
very very good holding chances in some
sort of endgame however earlier on it
looked like it was a position for the
two bishops
and as Bishop takes a five and these
these these pieces really started to
dominate the position here for tie-down
off now he's only just played Queen
takes b5 so this is a very very
temporary pawn that he's taken however
if we envision a position where maybe
the knight and Bishop get exchanged
maybe the Queen's get exchanged as well
black just brings his rooks to the B
file has pressure on the b2 maybe plays
rook before and I think blacks got more
than enough compensation there that
being said it's not in Caetano his best
interest just simply trade into that
that's not gonna happen so that's what
black would like but I don't think we're
gonna see that from from katana and
Stein Grimson very safely talks his King
away with King g8 in this position he
doesn't want that King out there exposed
for any type of like crossfire check
that may appear sometimes they're
calculating variations and you know if
this looks good that looks good
but then there's this like random check
at the end of all the variation so
sometimes you just tuck your king away
to get out of some check that you see at
the end of the variation in order to to
make it work in big news we have a lot
of people just joining us for the first
time today welcome I
we were invisible to you before but if
you're just joining us then Simon along
with Grandmaster Amnon Hambleton here
for the call the 2019 the spring chess
classic so welcome we have three games
already finished in our group a and all
of Group B is still underway okay so now
we have finally glanced at all of the
games and we have a very active chat
room now thank you for joining us we
have Patrick Daly joining us Patrick
thank you very much for your insight
Evon Chuck is always in time trouble he
says well let's anything new happening
in Avant Chuck and I was just checking
that game it's it's pretty surprising to
me how I mean it's chasms and ups term
turns I was gonna say was really
surprising that hang on a sec he's up
two pawns in the Queen side but then I
realized last move was c4 just giving it
up so clearly with intentions here as I
think Kasim Jono can really consider the
move Knight to b6 or at least as my
understanding that's his intention 96
hitting the rook with the bishop and if
I move the rook well I can't go here
which I would love to go the move Knight
takes e4 happens next and then I'm
hitting b2 and I'm hitting a 5 so I
think that's his I think that's his
intention there no I don't think
but to be too crazy there's no tricks
here I was just wondering why kazanova
was thinking because I don't see any
other night most ninety-five not an
option they here doesn't look any good
it feels like you have to play the movie
Knight b6 take take your pawn back and
quite frankly I don't I don't see any
other moves here so what's wrong with a
Knight of 6 just there's nothing well
the the issue is that the last move was
a voluntary pawn sack so if I'm not just
gonna take him back next move then then
I don't get the pawn sack at all so 9 up
6 fine move but ok I move my rook what
what have you been up to because now I
got two extra pawns here I'm gonna play
b4 b5 take this run this pawn all the
way I'm just sort of wondering what
whether he's sometimes chess players do
this I'm guilty as well where you know
you're gonna play one move but you sit
there thinking about the next move after
even though there's 100% chance you're
about to play let's say Knight b6 in
this case maybe he's sitting there
thinking okay Knight b6 where does his
rook go and then where do I go after
that when maybe he should just play it
because he's gonna play it anyway and
just see what Yvan Chuck is gonna have
in response but yeah I don't see another
move than 96 here so I'm really
expecting that I'm expecting Knight
takes back on c4 and I'm really
wondering what is what's being missed
here because yeah 96 looks looks like
the move here you found show got 41
seconds so that is the time trouble that
the chat is talking about and also in
group a our leader from Vietnam Liam Lee
and var Akopian I'm wondering if these
rooks are gonna be traded off soon or at
least a pair of them and we get into
some kind of a pawn game here anyone
have an advantage here do you see any
kind of breakthrough am i well this has
sort of developed the way that I thought
where var is really trying to refuse the
exchange on e5 because in any case it's
going to fix the pawns as expected the
White King went to eat
three no it was actually by blacks
invitation here with the move III check
but the idea remains the same that the
brook swings over to h8 you can take
that pawn in h4 and this is actually I
think developing fairly evenly that the
time is even for both players we have
pressure on h2 here and whites the
pressure in the position for white is
that these rooks do not want to get
exchanged from blacks point of view or
if they do it has to be white point rook
takes rook you don't want to take only
five and undal or uh nice late those
pawns so yeah I still think that this
one is is probably headed towards a draw
is it possible DS I guess it's possible
but how likely do you think it is that
we're gonna have ten draws today all ten
draws all ten nothing changes I think
it's definitely possible maybe even a
good chance for five draws in the a
group in the B group I think that my
issue is with the Arenberg bearish
poet's game which I just feel like
there's gonna be a result there because
of the way Arenberg is playing and the
time trouble that he was in also let's
not forget by Jin she is well it seemed
that he was playing for the win against
Nicholas Teodoro
can we look at that ehrenberg in bearish
bullets game yep
did Aaron bird just blunder somehow well
Mistah and Catterick just drew so
there's another step okay on the way to
your your ten draws but were you talking
about Theodore he said no Aaron Berger e
versus bearish Poland's right yeah this
was one of the ones I was sort of saying
you know there's a good chance for maybe
a result here so what what did he go for
rook takes King takes okay this was
actually one of the lines we'd looked at
and I was saying Queen c6 King e7 Queen
c5 King e8 so he's got his draw here
right he's guys draw on the board
check check check check he decides in
this position
it's actually go for he plays the Knight
takes c6 what was I thinking here after
king e7 I can't member if I had another
move but usually when you're calculating
a tricky sacrifice and you find a draw
for yourself it means it's a good
sacrifice you know like if you could
find a draw then you may find better but
you always have that draw to fall back
on so it's a really nice feeling
what about Queens e5 well that's what
that's what he was doing he was doing
this sort of check check check check and
then he got overwhelmed with the idea
developed inside him he was like Knight
to c6
this is the move I have to play it so he
checked and then played Knight takes c6
and after Queen takes rook is now
defending that that guy there and if
Queen takes here he's gonna play King f8
rook check takes Queen ae8 and you
survive and the King shuffles over and
you feel like eventually we'll get out
to h7 and then I hate that rook comes
into play and you should be doing well
there so he's actually played Queen c5
Queen takes b4 a5 trying to kick that
Queen off this diagonal so the King can
run Queen d4 King f8 and with a minute
on the clock
Wolf's Arenberg I guess he's just moved
night c5 but yeah he's he's in a tough
position here where I don't see a clear
conversion for for white seems to have
slipped from the last position we saw
maybe it was best for him to take that
draw maybe he just didn't want you to be
right about 10 draws you really should
have taken it has this has it happened
to you recently where you saw yourself
hey I've got a draw I've got an out and
you decide oh I'm gonna go for it and
then it just bites you in the rear end
almost all the time almost all the time
it's a really it usually happens when
you're playing lower rated player
because then you feel not necessarily
based on the position you start to think
too much in your head like I'm stronger
than am I
be playing for the win and you feel you
justify it somehow internally and that's
always a very bad idea that's the
opposite of what we were just talking
about yesterday right you're playing a
stronger opponent should I just take the
draw I just take the draw I don't know
if I should play on right it's a moral
victory right so he's played Queen d6
and it's looking better and better for
Irish bullets as 20 seconds ticking down
and you can see on your screen there
that ehrenberg needs to come up with a
move any second now there it is what is
it gonna be Knight d7 check I mean I
think in this moment with the time
pressure there's just no way that he can
continue to find I'm gonna be very
impressive to continue to find move
after move here
97 check
so King g8 looks very good here has he
played it yes he's played King g8 and
you've got this night on d7 the Queen is
is sort of skewering the Queen in the
rook and he's saying look we can we can
exchange Queens here at the cost of upon
it's no bother to me because all I want
are the Queen's off the board black gets
the Queen's off should be winning and
he's played them with queen g4 because
he understands he doesn't really have a
chance with the Queen's off
I saw another game here in groupie Kai
Donovan Stein Grimson there's a lot of
pressure on a b6 night I'm wondering if
I wonder if we're gonna pop it so
there's a pin night on B 6:00 right
Bishop and Queen attacking it and White
has the C file is white dominating here
is this do you feel good for Gregory
kite Donald I think why did I don't know
about dominating white is white is very
clearly better I think I think that the
worst part about White's position is
that he needs a place for this King if
this pawns on h4 and I can sort of like
find a little hideout on h3 for my king
then I think everything changes because
I have that C file like you Mitch I have
the pin but if I'm worried constantly
about the back rank where my king or
like you know this rook coming down the
Queen coming down and joining I don't
think I have time or confidence to play
any of these moves that I want to play
one idea is let's say in this position
if white plays um of age for let's say
and I played rook d2 I want to play
Queen Shaq and you know just go and meet
you
Bishop takes some guarding that's square
for now let's save rook takes so
renewing this threat rook c8 winning the
Queen of course it's going to come at
the cost of my own queen and that rook
line D 2 is actually there to cover the
d8 square so there are real threats for
black all of a sudden if you're not
paying attention it's like all of a
sudden boom rook d2 shows up in the
position Queen d4 is very hard to stop
and you may find yourself on the back
foot so you you while you're up a pawn
here is white and you've got that pin I
just think it's important that he
remains equally cautious as both players
are actually capable of getting mated in
this position I think the the only
reason why it's not just dominating here
is because of that King but tactically
it may and he's played the move h4 by
the way makes a lot of sense he knows he
needs to play King here and King here if
he gets that very confident what's his
next move probably rook c6 adding more
pressure very hard pin to get out of I
would give consideration to this
rook t2 as I'm looking more and more at
the position I start to wonder about
rook c8 kind of a insane move wondering
if it's working my idea is that if you
take with the rook that I want to take
this way and if you take with the Queen
my bishop is actually hitting your rook
there but the more logical move would be
Knight takes and I mean who knows what's
happening here this Queen D for coming
there's Queens hanging all over the
place probably a risky type of idea but
who knows what's gonna happen here h4
has been played he needs to get his King
age three and it's Stein Grimson to
think right now as you can see on your
screen there the well illuminated Kadena
of and the Dark Horse Stein Grimson the
room doesn't actually look like that by
the way I mean someone watching this
relay might think man they play in
little darkness like my candle light no
it's just how the cameras adjust to the
room typically when you see tournaments
like the Sinquefield Cup in the u.s.
championship we have like this
professional lighting over every board
we just don't have that they do have
room lighting it is sufficient we have
lamps available if any of the players
need more light so that is not a 100%
accurate representation of how that room
actually looks objects in the camera may
be brighter than they appear really
looks pretty dark over there for our
Icelandic code pow well yeah there
appears darker than it is can we discuss
this for 10 more minutes so it's darker
and it appears objects in the camera may
appear darker
I said objects in the camera may be
darker than they appear
did you say that that's what I said well
the chat can confirm all I know is I
really need to win this point from you
here
I just don't know what to think anymore
okay I've just had it I've just had it
all right can we glanced back at Aaron
Berger bearish bullets bars poets I
think this is where we're gonna get a
result I think it's going down I think
it's going down I don't know if we're
getting the result well we're definitely
trending in that direction okay somehow
he was able to get the Queen's off the
board and wasn't that hard Queenie six
what is he intending next rook d8 rook
d8 and after rook t8 you're pinned to d1
here and it I mean it forces this one of
Queen takes 95 so yes I think that that
was king f7 next and bars Pollux has
played it I feel like black is
completely on the way to a victory here
rook d7 check he's going to survive time
pressure no question but let's be clear
he is down a full exchange
he's down a full exchange here Ben and
it's gonna be it's gonna be a struggle
but I think that black is just winning
so I expect him to convert this to to be
what the first decisive game in Group B
this is this has been a different kind
of day and Andre just played King f6
this typically in a nine player or nine
rounds
Robin right I don't know if there's
empirical evidence to prove it but
there's a saying that the earth it's an
early day because people want to start
the rest day early in this term if
there's no rest day and we've seen a lot
of draws to start the day why is today
so different is there any idea you might
have why the players all of a sudden
today or you know something was in the
fruit punch upstairs yeah they all drank
it well I was positing the idea been
that they're just scared of being
interviewed by me so there
their games in record time yeah so that
they're they're finished before the
broadcast starts so I think they've had
a player's communion meeting and they've
all decided you know we're gonna send
maybe one guy down to the interview
slaughter but you know we don't all have
to suffer so they've decided that as a
group what happened to Cristy and
korilla in Group B Alexi Sorokin looks
like he's in much better position and
people in the chatter saying korilla has
blundered I don't know for sure what
happened here well I can tell you that
he's missing about four puns that he
used to have oh where did they go where
did they go okay so after Knight d2 rook
d1 I think that korilla maybe chose the
worst of of every variation here now I
can't confirm that because I probably
haven't thought about the position as
long as he has but from my first
impression here I thought that first of
all this this might be one move although
there's this shocker 94 I think it's
still playable right we were looking at
that position maybe with rook to c8
there and I thought that was that was
still reasonable now that being said the
other line we were looking at was maybe
d4 and then taking the rook versus the
two pieces now it wasn't great but I
felt with the shattered pawn structure
on the Kings side for white and the
outside past one for black that you know
you're you're definitely solid from
kirilus perspective he went for a knight
c4 and after B 396 what we actually see
here is the motif that I mentioned
earlier actually is relevant now so
again remember when I said after Queen
c2 that you know strong player is not
gonna let you play Queen takes g6 and
just meet you but the reason you play
this move is to just threaten the idea
time down a little bit both players are
sort of aware of it but at some point
that might come in handy again and right
now move Knight f4 was played and it's
not a queen but there's a threat there
to to the King so what was played rook
e8 overlooking Bishop takes g6 same idea
same idea on the board and gorilla is
going to be suffering after that
rook c8 rook t7 but he's given this
check but it is that's how all these
pawns got vacuumed off the board he
played the move rook takes d4 which is
just extremely powerful if you take here
nighty six Jack winning the house and so
he has to play King f6 King e5 f5 this
is all desperation he's pinned to the
rook here and he's lost all those King
side pawns so this game completely
flipped and is now in the favor of Lexie
Sorokin here who with extra time for
extra minutes here they're about to hit
time control he's gonna be looking at a
very very good position where he can
play for a win our favorite Romanian was
probably heartbroken when that happened
because yeah oh I saw this earlier but
again it's these these simple tactics
it's not like he really doesn't know the
idea but he saw it earlier he forgot
about it in time trouble and then it
came back to bite him I know how that is
no not at this level of course okay
let's jump back to our leaders game in
Group B Nikolas theodoro against the
leader by a ginchy it's been a little
bit since we've checked it out we've got
bishops of similar colors it has been a
lot of it since we checked that out and
I think that by June she has he's done
something wrong with this position
that's for sure it's unclear to me what
the necessarily the best plan would be
for for white in this position sorry for
black in this position this is where we
left it off we were saying well you know
he just has an extra pawn here but what
he decided to do was play c5 and you
sort of got in trouble with before and
the bishops a little loose it's so
uncomfortable when the King doesn't have
an escape square where it's being taken
away and actually white one is pawn back
and as a result he was able to throw
that pawn down the board and say look
I'm threatening checkmate in one that
you have to watch out for it and if you
let me play c7 let me say okay keep
going c3 if you let me play c7 and rook
f8 check that's gang well if I play c7
here for example when you play c2
maybe he's maybe as an idea I don't know
whether he's gonna play rook f8 right
now because actually both players are
about to Queen but okay I see actually
he did the exact same idea we can look
at the game he did he did rook F a check
so the idea being that if you take me
then I go Queen so you actually push the
pawn then Bishop a3 if you push this if
a I'm sorry if black pushes yeah right
and so we played this to stop that white
plays this to stop that pawn and now
it's actually black who has a pawn on a
dark square which is gonna favor white
with dark square Bishop you can sort of
bring that King in maybe but at the end
of the day I think you know black
supposed to play h5 fix upon on a dark
square this is probably probably just
the draw but seems like a good result
for Nicholas who sorted me to come back
there I didn't I mean just look like he
was down upon earlier but now it seems
like he's doing well and I have a
feeling that as he just hits time
control but that was by ginchy I think
that Nicholas is probably gonna draw
this game well you know the game it
might be a draw but it's interesting
enough to garner the attention of
Christian korilla saw him walking to the
tournament hall there doesn't want to
look at his own game anymore
no understandably I think he's just made
his 40th move in that game he's he's
coughed it up and he is looking to be in
dire straits in his game but the other
games in progress I think the other one
bargepole that's still very much in
command in his game stein Grimson and
kai donna of we see this game really
heating up and i have a feeling that cut
down off is probably on the verge of
checkmate here i think this is just over
we have rook c7 coming in if you take
the bishop or the pawn here i imagine
there's gonna be a checkmate for example
Queen takes e4 do not bring the rook
down that's gonna be matin one I mean H
one mate but we can do things with
checks and that's always better takes
here or sorry Queen g6 no matter where
the King goes give that check
the rook when it goes there and that is
checkmate so rook takes e4 has been
played but I mean unless okay so what he
wants is rook c7 hit think he wants to
play this last-ditch effort rook takes
h4 I'm I have a feeling that's what he
wants to do so that if pawn takes you
have this draw and if King takes you
have this draw back and forth so I think
that's what he's intending here but
Kodama plays the move Queen to g6 check
we will see King g8 or King h8 and then
I'm wondering how you deal with rook c7
so probably king let's say King h8 rook
c7 and if you bring the Queen over I I
just don't Queen here for example how
could we finish this off maybe just rook
here and rook d8 unstoppable seems to be
unstoppable at least and otherwise if
Queen g8 we could just do the same thing
here I even have the extra move rook d7
to e8 all the same I think it's just
game over and if we look once again at
that idea I just mentioned rook takes h4
the problem now I think although I
haven't calculated this one fully maybe
rook c7 doesn't quite work I was
thinking that a queen here we would have
like the blocking idea Queen back to g3
and that somehow you know we could just
get out of the checks cuz eventually
with my queen and king it does feel that
way but I was noticing there's also this
check to deal with so I don't know I
mean if that King is really gonna be
going for a jog here I don't know how it
ends up right well even with the you
mentioned the Queen blocking on g3
mm-hmm I don't I don't know that those
checks would stop from black right right
even in this line
there's Queen h1 and there's Queenie 4
so again I have to put up with all these
checks it's a it's a very tough position
so I think he's probably got to make a
more accurate move there we go that's
how it actually loses the game seems
like work age 4 is actually a serious
threat and one that he has to consider
here has he hit move 40 that's the
question I believe he has and that's
actually very fortunate for a katana
hitting move 40 right when he probably
needs all the time in the world to think
and if he gets this move right he may be
he's just winning so that's actually
extremely fortunate there for Chi danav
and because of that time to think I have
a feeling that she's probably gonna be
able to convert this alright very well
I want to glance over here to the
YouTube chat Denis Toki says why do you
not stream from the beginning st. Louis
chess club well that's a very good
question a lot of other tournaments are
from beginning to end we're only for 90
minutes around the time trouble up until
near the end and it's simply because
this is if we're going to stream and we
have 90 minutes to do it this is the
most exciting time to be on the air this
is typically the time we're gonna get
the most interviews and the most
thought-provoking positions on the board
all the time trouble yeah and we can
always go back and look at the openings
and how it happened that's what we do so
that is we just don't want to be on the
air for six hours basically and this is
when we're on the air so thank you for
your question Tommy LeBlanc says the
count fell asleep yes we agree thank you
very much okay so what else are we
looking at here I we are we have about
20 minutes left in the show and now that
kai donna and stein Grimson have made
time control it's unclear if we'll be
able to talk to Gregory in the case of
his victory ya know that that game looks
like it's gonna slow down a little bit
and also the chasm Genoa of game is very
likely very likely equal I would have to
say as well as the
laQuan Liam and Kobe in-game in the a
group so the the von Schuch one I mean
he finally did play that move might be
six and basically Kasim Jono of his he's
hit time control he just played the move
King f6 white played work age seven he
went back white went back so he's
deciding you know do I have better here
I honestly don't think that there is
necessarily this looks very very
balanced because if you try maybe the
King starts to get in here
the Bishop gets down there it's very
very double-edged also White can just
leave his King around g3 and f2 and just
shuffle so maybe he'll do that instead
but I have to say here that it feels
like this one is is sort of equal and
the other one in Group A is laQuan
against Cobian and this game also looks
like black is is actually making some
strides here a Cobian seems to have God
in the upper hand of these complications
so it doesn't look like we're gonna have
a clear leader in the field no
surprisingly it looks like pretty much
everyone tied at two and a half points
is now gonna be tied at three points in
the a group but Akopian just played with
King takes f5 and as far as I can see I
mean it's maybe not too relevant but
that looks like a pawn to me I mean you
move that rook F six blocks up a pawn
don't don't understand that so this one
looks like maybe bar with some chances
against look long who maybe over push an
endgame or maybe just underestimated the
moves or potentially there was a time
scramble there near move 40
let's glance back at Alexei Sorokin and
Christian korilla has Christian improved
his standing I well it looks like there
may not be much improving to have here
past H and G pawns for white Sorokin is
in the driver's seat yeah I know this
this looks like a big position for white
bishop f3 looks like a good move in fact
it's just been played it gets out of the
way if the H pawn clears it for from
motion and also if black would play what
I consider to be quite a big blunder
Bishop takes Bishop King takes what we
have is a position where if black ever
moves his rook white plays rook d5 check
and then wins the night because the King
can't go back so the rook is actually
tied to the knight and the only way out
of that is something like this the
knight move and then we get to trade the
Brooks and I believe that these two
connect pawns should probably be enough
to win in in this position here what do
we have on the board is probably a
slightly improved version of this he
does not trade and improve White's King
he just goes here cuz he knows he's
gonna have to make this move eventually
he goes Knight f7 and says okay look we
can trade the rooks but if you want to
trade the bishops you got to help my
King get closer I still feel like
in-game should be completely winning
with the to connect pass bones for
Sorokin though right we can see there on
the cam that the count is not too happy
with his position but the nice thing
about blacks position if I can ever find
one is that you you're kind of forced
into playing a certain way so he doesn't
have to think too hard about these moves
as they are they are pretty forest
and now kadanoff has played rook c7
bringing the pressure on to Stein
Grimson yeah I think that I think that
there's just a way out of that perpetual
if I spend or if I just think about the
position another time in my head I feel
that rook takes h4 takes Queen f3 King
h2 is probably the answer in order to
play Queen f2 Queen g2 and after Queen
takes h4 king g1 what's really nice is I
don't deal with this check because the
bishop covers it which is fantastic for
me so it has to be queen d4 and then I
feel like I can start running running
black out of checks here Queen f2 Queen
g4 and at the end of day let's not
forget I'm just up a row so I will
slowly be able to sort of like zigzag up
the board or or get over here and maybe
use my Bishop to block so I do think
that this is this is winning for for
Gregory I don't know if you very well
well I got to tell you guys today is a
very big day here on the chest campus
and not only are we having the spring
chess classic but right across the
street at the World Chess Hall of Fame
they're having a really big event
tonight because it's the opening of us
chess eighty year anniversary exhibition
on the third floor and if you've ever
been to the World Chess Hall of Fame
beautiful facility three floors the
first two floors are art galleries
typically they have something to do with
chess sometimes not so much the third
floor is where the proper halls of fame
are the world chess and u.s. chess halls
of fame right and the third floor is
where the US chess or USCF 80-year
exhibition is and it is really something
to behold
so tonight there's a big party they're
gonna open the exhibit it's gonna be
open through September or October I
think and actually just today the
executive director of the st. Louis
chess club Tony rich sat down with the
executive director of US chess Karel
Meyer and they talked all about
just everything the history of the
organization dating back to the Western
Chess Association which was a
predecessor organization Kenneth
Harkness do you know who can Harkness is
okay socially not if you're on your
chess history our patty Loew invented
the elo rating system which is what u.s.
chess and feed a basis their systems off
of the Harkness system predates the elo
system back in the 60s and they have a
big book from Kenneth Harkness himself
that has a whole bunch of calculations
an old game record it's really
interesting to look at and old trophies
and stuff just really historical items
that you might be surprised are still in
existence so if you're ever in st. Louis
I definitely recommend checking out the
US chess 80 year anniversary exhibit at
the Hall of Fame and the first two
floors are actually opening up with new
exhibits in another month so I mean
after the US champs you'll have some
fresh content there it's always a great
way to suspend your trip here in st.
Louis if you come by the st. Louis chess
club so for more information check out
world chess HOF org for information on
US chess 80 years I heard I heard that
there was gonna be an entire floor for
Bensimon the Bensimon exhibit yet is
that gonna be debuted and at this event
or saving and unveiling for later it's
under discussion give it another 50
years okay right and not only that
remember two weeks away two weeks away
is round one of the US Chess
Championship we have three competitors
in group jeffrey zhang ray Robson vara
Cobian playing in that so be sure to
check that out right here at us chess
champs calm we have another result in
group a our fourth draw of the day Avant
Chuck and cousin Jonathan Wright as
expected no surprises there that one
looked
look to be drawn we may in fact get five
draws from group a but it's gonna come
down to to whether var in the quang draw
their game but honestly bar has some
decent chances he's got that extra pond
and he will try and push the position is
he actually gonna win it I have my
doubts says it looks like the white
ropes are very very active in that game
in Group B Kai Donovan Stein Grimson
they've hit time control so he's gonna
think about this this rook sac we've
been looking at for for black but the
position is over and white is completely
winning there and I think bars pullets
is completely winning up the exchange
against Aaron Berg and by gen sheep
probably gonna draw against Nicholas
theodoro and probably the the game
that's you know still ongoing with the
most happening is Alexei Sorokin against
Christian korilla
and although it's definitely winning for
white there is still some play on the
board okay well we are wrapping up the
show unfortunately none of these games
ended in decisiveness while we were on
the air this is a first so at least none
of them ended indecisiveness before we
were on the air that's that's a good
thing yes we didn't miss we didn't miss
any big results it's actually just been
a slower day of chess today all around
in both the a and the B sections but
especially it looks are really likely to
have five draws in the a group today
you're a very positive person thank you
positive spin oh thank you Ben yeah
we're gonna bout to wrap up the show but
if actually if we have them I'd like to
take a look at the standings just to
kind of see where we are I mean look if
you saw at the top of the show it's the
same we still have that log jam where
Liam Lee well if he gets that draw
against a cobia and you mentioned a Kobe
and still has play right then we'll
still have that six way tie for first
after five days I think this is
surprising
to have so many people tied for first I
mean I'm always surprised actually when
someone sort of runs away with the
tournament because I always have the
impression that fields like this where
the the highest and lowest rating are
100 points apart give or take
everyone is so strong in and you we saw
Hanson beat laQuan Liana in this
tournament which is the lowest seat
being the number one seat
so when results like that can have an
internment like this I almost get the
impression nobody's safe and for someone
to just crush the field they would have
to be putting on like a 2,900 like
otherworldly performance to to really be
dispatching just about everyone that
comes their way so I have a feeling that
I always do expect it to actually be
really competitive between so many
players so while six tied at the top is
definitely you know something you don't
see every day I can't say it surprises
me too much as it's really hard to find
differences between the strengths of
these players if we looked at the
standings in Group B there's not a lot
solid together we've just had one draw
and we know that there's gonna be some
well there's probably going to be some
one O's or oh ones in the other games so
there's a lot of variables here anything
you're looking forward to going forward
among given the current scores well we
we definitely expect
Sorokin there to jump up to three points
actually
Sorokin kai down up and Bars po let's
all should be jumping up to three points
after today's round with wins there and
Nicholas theodoro will also maybe hold a
draw against by Jin cheese so it's
looking like a full point lead for by
Jin she at four points after today and
then maybe a lot of people actually at
three points chasing him so by Jin she
continues to extend his lead and
everyone else continues to beat each
other and sort of help him out you know
no one is is that two point five going
to win and jump up to 3.5 to catch up so
he is maintaining a good distance from
the pack right now and
staying on top of the tournaments quite
impressive all right well that's where
we're gonna leave you here today from
st. Louis it's been a pleasure as always
this show was produced by the world's
greatest production B team Tammy Hyde is
watching the stream making sure it
doesn't drop thank you very much and we
have Dani Machuca doing he's running the
show as a technical director Isaac ever
schrott Isaac's rants man I cannot talk
right now what is going on Isaac's
trance is running the audio and graphics
my name is Ben Simon and he's yes you
said your own name right that I did I've
been feeling you just shafting us now I
have a lot of getting your own name
right and just messing everyone else's
up and he is Grand Master am on
Hambleton got it yes yes
so tomorrow 1:00 p.m. as always that's
when the game starts at us chess champs
calm we are on the air at 3:30 p.m. two
and half hours later and until tomorrow
we say so long from the show-me-state
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you